il est décidément l'homme fort de
l'albâtre auzeral mcdo elle conserve son
titre au golf national au terme d'un
final haletant sous la pluie le nord
irlandais 12e joueur mondial a décroché
ce dimanche son deuxième alstom open de
france devant l'américain kevin stadler
évidemment nous reviendrons en détail
sur ce titre dans cette édition salut à
tous et bienvenue dans le dernier set 8
sport de la saison allez on passe tout
de suite au sommaire ce week-end au
vélodrome c'était la chasse aux
médailles la reine devait vite ce
accueillait ses premiers championnats de
france joris daudet s'est imposé chez
les hommes et manon valentino est titré
chez les femmes cette saison elle a
décroché deux titres de championne de
france de gymnastique à tout juste 17
ans jacques faty seront à remporter le
concours général et au sol c'est notre
portrait de la semaine c'est la nouvelle
activité à la mode sur les terrains le
foot bulle où la nouvelle façon de jouer
au foot avec une confection cette fois
ci remplit d'air qui vous protège de
tous les chocs évidemment comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission l'essentiel
du week-end mais tout d'abord place à
notre page spéciale golfe
après quatre jours de compétition de
haute volée au terme d'un final à
suspense graeme mcdowell a conservé son
titre à l'alstom open de france ce
dimanche et côté français quelques
heures plus tôt tout le monde n'avait
d'yeux que pour le prodige victor
dubuisson résumé réalisé avec olivier
maniscalco
de mémoire de golfeurs lors d'un premier
tour on avait rarement vu autant de
monde autour du départ du trou numéro 1
de l'albatros personne ne veut louper
l'entrée en lice du numéro un français à
commencer par le secrétaire d'état aux
sports en visite au golf national
contrairement à d'autres quoi je pense
au tennis ou lorsqu'il ya un grand
tournoi on sait que ces trois ou quatre
joueurs qui peuvent gagner là à chaque
fois sont une vingtaine dans les vins a
toujours des français c'est vrai que
cette année tout le monde met la
pression sur victor dubuisson il a
quatre jours pour bien peu tes pas faire
d'erreurs et on sera derrière lui la
seule
pour ce premier tour victor dubuisson va
affronter l'albatros aux côtés de deux
grands favoris le tenant du titre graeme
mcdowell est le favori allemand martin
kaymer récent vainqueur de l'us open
mais ce que personne n'osait croire
arrive dès le premier drive le 22e
joueur mondial sera complètement et
envoie sa balle hors du fairway après
deux trous il se retrouve même à quatre
coups du par bon il vient ici
en favori quoi avec tout tout le public
qui le porte et je pense que ça ira
mieux un petit peu de la pression mais
je vais des très grands joueurs donc ça
va le tirer vers le haut et ça le
stimule et je pense qu'elle a un gros
mental va revenir dans la partie
malheureusement pour ses supporters le
numéro un français ne se remet pas de ce
triple bogey il finira cette première
journée à +5 loin derrière la
démonstration de l'américain kevin
stadler qui pour sa première apparition
sur l'albatros se retrouve seul en tête
avec une carte de 64
lots de consolation côté tricolore c'est
un autre victor élus qui occupent la
place de premier français au plus au 1er
tour au sixième rang sur les deuxième et
troisième jours le titre semble s'offrir
à stadler toujours imperturbable
avec dans son sillage l'étonnant victor
riu solide dauphin à quatre coups mais
ça c'était avant que la pluie s'en mêle
dimanche habib de tempête sur le golf
national mais aussi dans les mains de
kevin stadler l'américain de 34 ans
craque complètement et se fait croquer
par graeme mcdowell pourtant parti avec
huit coups de retard
le nord irlandais arrivé au club house
en leader mais doit attendre le dernier
trou de stadler si l'américain rentrer
ce dernier putt il peut s'offrir une
mort subite
un raté qui offre la victoire à mcdowell
le nord-irlandais conserve son groupe il
ya là le grand retour d'un vainqueur
lors d'un dernier tour de l'histoire du
tour
aujourd'hui c'était une bonne journée je
ne m'attendais pas à gagner j'ai
beaucoup de chance d'être assis à côté
de ce trophée
la plus grosse différence pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est lé fairway avec la
pluie c'est drôle comment l'eau a rendu
deroff plus dense ils sont devenus plus
lourd et la balle plutôt que de
s'arrêter sur le rough avait tendance à
glisser
j'ai été chanceux mais j'ai dû aussi
joué de nombreux coups sur le fairway
et vous l'avez eue dans ce résumé la
bonne surprise côté français est venue
du côté de l'illinois formé à saint nom
la bretèche victor riu et malgré une fin
de partie compliquée un dimanche le
tricolore termine à une belle 8e place
cet open de france 2014 et les meilleurs
français et surtout il décroche son
ticket pour le british open dans deux
semaines
je suis vraiment content pour coup et
carrément être quelques et politiques
et
c'est sûr qu'après je crois 10 gt co
leader et je suis je pense à mettre un
peu de pression peut-être jeu des lieux
dur de regarder les serveurs dossier ce
moment là où j'ai commencé à jouer un
peu petit bras surtout putting je
pensais rester cours et voilà
très satisfait et avec cette huitième
place et les 75000 euros en poche qui
vont avec victor riu fait également un
grand pas en vue de conserver ses droits
de jeu pour la saison prochaine sur
l'european tour
lors de la première journée de l'open de
france le secrétaire d'état aux sports
thierry braillard est venu assister à
quelques parties mais le sujet de
discussion principal était du côté des
responsables de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est
évidemment la préparation de la ryder
cup 2018 projet sur lequel les élus
locaux attendent des réponses de l'état
sur sa participation au financement de
l'événement dans le budget devrait
s'élever à 6 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui en pleine préparation
à se rendre septembre en écosse là ce
sera le dernier parcours européen avant
que nous passons le relais et en clair
d'entraînement dans le monde très très
important et en attendant les listes
qu'il confirme
l'étape
la participation à cette organisation
se prépare l'état va soutenir soutient
déjà et on va se tenir je crois que
savoir plus pas d'exposition et ses
compagnons à la politique de
popularisation
aujourd'hui quasiment
indice parler
qui aurait dit ça ya maintenant
allez on enchaîne avec les championnats
de france de bmx qui se déroulait ce
week-end du côté du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et vous le
voyez cet homme est le nouveau patron du
bmx français ce samedi joris daudet a
remporté les france sur la reine du
vélodrome le pilote licencié au stade
bordelais s'est imposé devant le grand
favori quentin caleyron et damien godet
après une finale à couteaux serré
ouais c'est super je suis revenu des
etats unis lundi donc c'était un peu
compliqué voilà c'est super de gagner le
titre de nouveau je suis content mais
après quelques saisons un peu difficile
c'est toujours bien d'avoir un titre
ouais ouais c'était compliqué la piste
est vraiment difficile les virages
hoover donc quand tu es en tête c'est
pas c'est pas facile de savoir où sont
les autres et voilà quand on fait une
belle course et j'espère que public a
aimé ça eva rivas finir en tête donc
c'est cool et le plateau de pilotes
étaient encore une fois exceptionnel ce
week-end le champion de france junior en
titre romain mahieu passé depuis chez
les élites féfé faisait un parti des
grands barbe des grands battus car son
chemin s'est même arrêtée en quart de
finale romain a chuté dans le deuxième
virage claire cambier a recueilli ses
premières impressions à la sortie de la
piste
romain avec ton titre l'année dernière
j'imagine que tu vises et une première
place qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu être un peu fait
un peu trop gourmand sur la section pro
je pensais qu'il pouvait doubler et
quentin qui était premier finalement en
arrivant dans le jura je me suis aperçu
que sa fin que ça passait pas j'essaie
d'imiter dégâts pour rester derrière lui
et ça c'est pas passé j'ai glissé
c'est la course
c'est aussi le jeu et est ce que la
piste était compliquée du coup et non la
piste des cités roulant ça roulait bien
il n'y a pas de grosses difficultés
juste la section pro à plat se faire
surprendre de vouloir trop l'attaqué et
là c'est juste tactique je vais
peut-être dû attendre un peu derrière
lui il ya de vouloir à tout prix passer
devant mais on apprend de ses erreurs
donc
ramello prochaine j'imagine un peu d'ici
du coup un peu déçu c'est ma première
année unités
j'espérais mieux qu'un quart de finale
de suite sur surtout que j'en étais
capable d'aller beaucoup plus loin j'ai
fait je fais des finales en coupe de
france l'année des podiums donc un peu
déçu mais c'est ça c'est c'est sur une
course et c'est le sport j'en parlais
dans les titres chez les femmes la reine
de l'hexagone s'appelle manon valentino
a pris un super départ la parisienne a
commis quelques fautes 1 en finale mais
elle conserve la tête 1 jusqu'au bout
devant eva ailloud la septuple
championne du monde magali pauthier
manon valentino décroche là son
troisième titre national dans sa
carrière et surtout réussi le doublé
après 2013 inutile de vous dire que
c'était un gros soulagement après avoir
résisté à la pression et à ce statut de
favorite
je suis c'était mon titre et ça oblige
les lions en 2011 en 2012 j'étais en
tête et je me suis fait doubler ça
m'avait est extrêmement mal on va dire
j'avais dit que tout ça en 2013 les rues
vraiment à compte énormément et en paix
je me rends compte que même si on a déjà
eu des maillots s'il troisième que j'ai
là en france
toujours s'avère chez les juniors c'est
le pilote du vaucluse xavier gonzalez
bernard qui s'est imposé et côté féminin
la numéro un française 110 thibault
décroche le titre un titre qui suit sa
sélection avec l'équipe de france pour
les championnats d'europe toujours chez
les juniors au milieu de tous ces
pilotes internationaux que vous avez
vues sur ces images d'eux yvelinois
étaient en lice dans cette catégorie
dont steven thierry licencié au club de
voisins-le-bretonneux son objectif était
de se qualifier en seizièmes de finale
mission accomplie mais malheureusement
pour le jeune vie si noah et malgré sa
bonne connaissance de la piste où il
s'entraîne régulièrement maintenant la
belle aventure s'arrête à ce stade de la
compétition
steven ne terminant que sixième de sa
manche
c'est dur il ya du contact faut bien
prendre une brosse une bonne première
ligne y aller à fond direct ou le fait
de connaître la piste c'est un gros gros
avantage c'est un avantage de connaître
la piste parce que le start ski et 90 %
de la course on le connaît et après faut
dérouler sa course il allait y aller
puis voilà
sans transition place à la gymnastique
trois titres de champion 1 par équipes
et deux en individuel deux podiums
nationaux la saison 2014 du jem le club
de gymnastique d'elancourt mort pas été
pour le moins exceptionnel va-t-on dire
et on va là débriefer ce soir avec
boumédiène bendaoud vous êtes
l'entraîneur des sommes du côté national
du côté du jem bonsoir à vous soit 7,8
sport alors tout d'abord première
question quelle est la recette du succès
pour avoir tous ces résultats si positif
cette saison la recette c'est le travail
et l'assiduité de tous les gymnastes aux
entraînements et puis surtout l'envi de
l' envie de bien faire c'est on peut pas
réussir si on n'aime pas ce qu'on fait
en tant qu'entraîneur des hommes est ce
que vous aviez senti un petit peu
pressenti c'est bon c'est bon résultat
en fin de saison vous senti le coup
venir un petit peu comme on dit et ben
non et non en fait on pressent toujours
mais l'adversité tels que on n'est
jamais sûr des résultats ça dépend pas
sa dépense jamais que de nous c'est vrai
que la génétique et 1 est un sport un
petit peu ingrat et surtout il faut
avoir faire preuve en tout cas de
beaucoup de rigueur et c'est vrai que
c'est sûrement le travail de plusieurs
années peut-être la formation que de
jeunes gymnastes que vous avez tout
petits au club exactement en fait il
faut que toutes les personnes soient à
leur pic de forme au bon moment et le
jour j est ce qu'on peut qualifier cette
saison 2013-2014 de meilleure saison de
l'histoire du club où il y en a d'autres
qui est par le passé qu'ils ont été
encore plus forte que ça c'est l'une des
meilleures parce que on a en a plusieurs
médailles
chez les masculins et chez les féminines
mais il ya eu il ya eu par le passé
quand même aussi un titre de champion de
france par équipes et plus plusieurs
titres de champion de france individuel
pour les nommer on va évidemment les
nommer jacques pâtissons chez les
féminines a été double championne de
france nationale b 17 ans concours
général et au sol il ya eu aussi marie
cécile guilbaud médaillé de bronze
nationale b 18 ans et plus et tommy j'ai
envie champion de france national ses 18
ans et puis l'équipe homme que vous
connaissez un peu plus donc champion de
france de nationale 7 tous ces bons
résultats pour les avoir cessé gina cela
vous les avez fait travailler très peu
très jeune en fait pour atteindre ce
niveau il faut commencer très petit
parce que il n'y a pas de secret la
gymnastique est un sport très ingrat
très difficile on n'obtient pas de
résultats si on ne travaille pas depuis
très longtemps comment vous les avez
ensuite sélectionné c'est une sorte de
sélection naturelle dans cette
discipline c'est le travail qui permet
de passer des paliers entre guillemets
exactement fait s'est il n'y a pas de
sélection en fait c'est c'est le groupe
le groupe masculin c'est celui qui
persistent qui restent donc en fait
c'est plus la sélection est entre
guillemets oui naturel parce que ceux
qui n'accroche pas au qu'il n'arrive pas
arrête ou ceux qui ne s'amuse plus
est-ce qu'il faut spécifier c'est que la
plupart de ces gymnastes qui ont été
titrés ou qui sont montés sur les
podiums cette saison ce sont des menaces
qui ont vraiment été des purs produits
on va dire elancourt maurepas en tout
cas qui ont grandi quand même sur les
praticables et les à gré de votre club
et ça c'est exactement ce qu'est la
réussite c'est la spécificité oui
effectivement c'est le fait qu' ils se
connaissent tous et se connaissent tous
depuis très longtemps donc c'est un
élément qui n'est pas négligeable
l'objectif quand on a une saison comme
ça qui vient de s'achever c'est de voir
encore plus haut j'imagine en tant
qu'entraîneur on a envie d'aller
chercher d'autres titres d'autres
podiums la saison prochaine bah c'est
déjà deux de d'essayer de faire aussi
bien c'est très difficile parce que
comme je vous ai dit l'adversité elle
est allée tels que
ça ne dépend pas que de nous donc voilà
il faut que tout le monde soit en forme
le au bon moment le bon jour et puis si
s'il travaille bien pourquoi pas est ce
qu'il ya justement encore un potentiel
de progression à tous ces jeunes
gymnastes ah oui oui il ya encore du
potentiel de progression alors par
rapport à tous ces gymnastes on en a
rencontré une spécifiquement cjad
pâtissons qui a été double championne de
france je vous propose de regarder son
portrait donc je le disais tout à
l'heure championne de france concours
général et au sol sont à gré préféré on
regarde tout ça avec des images de
patrick jacq de dixinn
ne vous fiez pas son regard d'ange
pâtissons est bel et bien la reine d
agréer savait-elle à peine marcher
qu'elle voulait faire comme les grandes
ces gymnastes à l'élégance rare sur un
praticable très vite intégré dans le
système du sport études à tout juste
huit ans jade place la gymnastique au
centre de sa vie à l'âge où les autres
enfants continuent de découvrir le monde
y en a beaucoup conduit mal parce que du
coup on n'a pas forcément le temps de
jouer quand on est petit ou mais moi je
trouve que c'est bien parce que du coup
ça nous apprend à gérer notre temps on
sait pourquoi on vient quand on a le
temps pour travailler à l'école on
travaille à l'école et d'ailleurs ça
aide beaucoup je trouve ce que la
rigueur qu'on à la gym on l'a aussi
quand on est à l'école futurs élèves de
terminale scientifique jacques pâtissons
a su transposer la rigueur du praticable
à l'école et après plusieurs exercices
dans l'élite le travail et le talent ont
payé
jade a décroché cette saison deux titres
de championne de france sur le concours
général et au sol sa spécialité enfin le
rêve
tout le travail depuis le début
enfin ça paye et ça fait plaisir après
un premier titre à la poutre il ya
quelques années ce doublé a une saveur
toute particulière la gymnastique
chinoise est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium en même temps que son
petit frère
c'était vraiment ça m'a fait pleurer
déjà j'avais les larmes aux yeux mais en
plus avec est le petit frère c'était
vraiment magique et pull il méritait
tellement aussi c'était vraiment c'était
au début on n'a pas réalisé mais après
quand je les réalise et c'est une
infamie
lorsqu'elle quittera les agréent jade
aimerait volé dans le monde du spectacle
nul doute que les projecteurs se
braquent gros un jour sur sa grasse
et jade est l'exemple parfait dont deux
seront 30 on parlait il ya quelques
minutes c'est un pur produit en fin de
compte de votre club même s'il ya la
distance elle n'est pas la bible pas sûr
sur saint quentin mais elle est là
depuis très très longtemps oui voilà et
justement quand on voit une jeune
gymnaste comme ça arriver au plus haut
niveau quand on l'a vu peut-être grandir
c'est un sentiment particulier en tant
qu'entraîneur bah c'est pour moi c'est
difficile à dire parce que je m'occupe
pas du tout des jeunes filles mais
effectivement quand on a quelqu'un qui
sort du cru et puis qu'on a qu'on a
suivi depuis le début c'est un
aboutissement de le voir évoluer à ce
niveau là bien sûr on parlait tout à
l'heure de cette sélection entre
guillemets naturel
au niveau des paliers pour continuer de
progresser comment vous voulez repéré
sait jamais il n'a de cesse qu'il ya des
qualités intrinsèques un bon gymnastes
oui il ya des qualités naturelles de
souplesse et de force qui sont qui sont
intrinsèques les cons qu'on détecte tout
de suite après c'est pas c'est pas une
généralité il y a il ya des exceptions
qui font que même si on a moins de
qualités de souplesse ou de force on
peut en travaillant réussir à faire des
très bon niveau et en tout cas ça sent
est la preuve puisqu'il ya eu beaucoup
de bons résultats cette saison
félicitations donc aux clubs d'elancourt
maurepas et puis on espère vous
retrouver l'année prochaine sur de
nombreux podiums merci beaucoup william
d'être passés sur le 7-8 sport c'est la
nouvelle activité à la mode sur le
terrain je vous en parlais dans les
titres de ce set 8 sport le foot bulle
où la nouvelle façon de jouer au foot
mais avec une protection rempli d'air
qui vous protège de tous les chocs
nous ne sommes pas dans un parc
d'attractions ces jeunes joueurs vont
bien s'essayer au football ici même
principe que le football classique il
faut marquer un but de plus que
l'adversaire en version trois contre
trois où 55 est l'outil indispensable
la bulle aussi facile à enfiler qu'un
sac à dos grâce à cette protection les
joueurs peuvent rouler tomber et subir
tous les chocs les plus spectaculaires
sont jamais risquer la blessure on peut
aller au contact mais c'est bien c'est
bien ouais en train de danser bien c'est
dur parce qu'on voit pas la balle sinon
après c'est facile en résumé le principe
des autos tamponneuses redevient roi ici
au football pas besoin d'être un zidane
du ballon rond pour s'amuser sur le
terrain au contraire c'est que ça permet
à tout le monde de jouer non joue avec
des femmes des enfants c'est toujours
marrant parce que c'est vrai que l'
équilibre change un petit peu parfois on
a des gens qui se loupe pour taper dans
la balle c'est même plutôt rigolo
surtout qu'après il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui est là pour un peu rentré
dans l'autre le tamponnais comme on
raconte et puis il ya une galipette
derrière une roulade sans jamais se
faire mal c'est sur sa canne 320 euros
c'est le coût d'une heure complète de
jeu pour deux équipes et aussi
surprenant que cela puisse paraître le
football est une excellente activité
physique pour de nombreux sportifs ça
peut être complémentaire de d'énormément
de sport parce qu'au terme de
préparation physique c'est quand même
quelques kilos sur le dos donc
ça va travailler différemment sur les
gens à travailler au niveau du cardio
mais après ça peut amener des enfants
qui auraient eu des réticences au
contact à faire quelque chose de nouveau
vous voyez le foot bull c'est une autre
façon de jouer au foot c'est très
spectaculaire et ludique et surtout on
ne se blesse pas
magnifique ce sport
est un sport apprécié par l'ensemble de
la rédaction allez on passe à
l'essentiel du week-end
six mois après son ouverture le
vélodrome nationale a déjà franchi une
barre symbolique celle d'emile baptême
sur la piste en marge des championnats
de france de bmx ce week-end steve roy
c'est son nom était mis à l'honneur ce
samedi soir et pour l'occasion il a eu
le droit en tant que millièmes baptisé
un maillot dédicacé par les membres de
l'équipe de france et surtout un morceau
de la piste et c'était super sympa on a
été on a été bien accueillie
voilà bah moi surtout g1 du vélo de juin
du vélo de route donc c'était vraiment
des sensations différentes et
franchement c'était super agréable
de revenir est tout à fait je me suis
créé un compte sur le site
voilà donc je vais revenir j'ai pas eu
le temps parce que j'ai eu une naissance
mais je vais revenir rapidement parce
que c'est une passion plus et je trouve
que c'est très bien ici
mais avant de se quitter des nouvelles
traditionnelle de nos deux rameurs
yvelinois après 28 jours de cours sur la
great pacific crest cela va un peu moins
bien il faut le dire pour christophe
papillon et clément et lieu originaire
de millemont dans les yvelines à bord de
leur bateau la cigogne ils ont perdu
deux places au classement général pour
se retrouver 7e et ils ont également
perdu une place au classement général
des bateaux en duo depuis leur départ
début juin ils ont déjà parcouru près de
900 mille îles je vous le rappelle un
leur challenge est gigantesque
puisqu'ils doivent relier à la rame et
sans escale sans escale par dont la
californie hawaï ce sont environ 3900 km
à vol d'oiseau c'est la fin de ce
dernier sept huit sports de la saison et
si vous l'avez vous avez pu le suivre
toute l'année c'est grâce aux personnes
de l'ombre romain russe fini merci à lui
pour le montage la réalisation avec
sandrine fontaine xavier jaglin et
l'équipe de reporters sur le terrain je
vous souhaite un excellent était sur
téléphiles et surtout vive le sport